it's great to be joined today by Helen
turski who is a physicist at University
College London also author of the book
storm and a teacup the physics of
everyday life Helen it's so great to
speak to you know we talk so often about
science lately one particular area of
interest is climate change but
particularly when we think about media
coverage of these issues there are so
many ways in which the average person
may feel like these are inaccessible
issues in the sense of knowing the
reality and with climate change its
partially because of misinformation and
also partially because we are dealing
with really big and important topics so
let's start as broadly as possible from
your view as a scientist why is it that
many sort of lay people come away
feeling as though maybe science is best
left to the academics is that by design
it's certainly not five design of the
academics anymore maybe it was a hundred
years ago you know name of making
herself feel clever but I think that is
absolutely not the case today scientists
are very enthusiastic about what they
understand about the world they're keen
to share it and they're keen to include
as many people as possible in the
discussion and that's really important
but i think that the it's sometimes hard
to feel included and there's a few
reasons for that and one of them is that
science is something people have the
perception at school that scientists
something you get wrong you know you get
it right where you get it wrong and if
you get it wrong it's all bad and nasty
and you get big you know kind of black
mark and and and it is the case that we
have found out through experiments over
many years that there are basic things
about how the way the world works that
we understand very well you know the
laws about what happens when you push
something or you know if you drop
something it falls down the Sun laws we
understand very well and they are things
that you can get right and the problem
is that that kind of merges into this
world where you know even though it's
very simple although you know causing a
lot of things around as physics laws and
the we live in a very complex world and
so things interact
you know it's not just something fall
down it's just something else in the way
and if you're dealing with something
like a cloud for example to take the
weather you know those will be things
that affect the cloud and it's still
ruled by the same physical laws but
they're much harder to see because it's
all so complicated so I think it has
become difficult because it's very
difficult now to explain modern science
in one or two sentences you know it's
some things in size we can say well you
know the reason your towel soaks up
water so well is because of this thing
called capillary action you can explain
how it works and it's quite simple but
but often in the real world it seems a
lot more complicated and I think was not
necessarily done very well as fire just
conveying the difference between I'd oh
and it's complicated and I can't tell
you everything in two minutes and so
it's just that we need a statistic ated
discussion around science but absolutely
everyone should feel included is this
partially a sort of side effect or
consequence of in the political world
often we go towards if it's complex or
nuance or difficult to explain a
politician is probably lying to you and
this creates a bias away from complexity
and towards simplicity is this may be
impacting the average person's not
necessarily ability but maybe
willingness to hear complexity the
provision is human brain because human
brain is always looking for shortcuts
and they're always looking for patterns
and you remember something much better
if it fits a pattern that you understand
and the problem with complex systems is
that you know the reason they're
complexes they don't fit an obvious
happening and why is this cloud this
shape well it's lots of different things
and but our brains are looking for like
the simple pattern that that makes life
easy and that's the survival skill like
there's so much information in the world
around if you know just the person
walking through the world there's cars
and as radiation of sounds and the stuff
going on and if you can't pay attention
to all of it so your brain has got
really good at picking out the patterns
that matter and the problem is that now
we're more educators we have a more
sophisticated understanding of the world
we've still got this brain that goes
right where's a nice simple person and
when it sees a simple cabinet locks onto
it like one of those optical illusions
you know where you don't see it
till someone told you what it is and
then you can't not see it right it's
exactly like that so in the case of
complex issues I think politicians who
have a very short period of time to
anything love saying simple things
because you booger oh right that's a
pattern I remember that now I can move
on and the problem is the pattern
doesn't represent reality because we do
live in a complex world you know we're
kind of stuck with it and so we have to
constantly be remembering that there's
more nuanced so the politicians does
cleared of suspicion of politicians now
because the simple messages you know
which are which are designed to kind of
click into that pattern fitting bit of
the brain and are now seen as distortion
because we we know this probably more
stuff going on but we're not sure and
you know which which where the
complexity is and the thing here is that
we can always we have to remember to
look for ourselves if you know if you
understand the framework of the way the
world works so for example if you know
the basic physical laws you know the way
that physics kind of controls what's
going on you can spot the shorts
patterns that are really just blatant
Alton ratting out lies and the ones that
might actually be credible so having a
basic knowledge of science helps you
select which of the patterns are likely
to be reasonable or not and that's one
of the reasons that are basic
understanding a scientist such an
important thing because it lets you sort
out the patterns that are likely to real
it's like the first filter that lets you
distinguish between what's likely to be
a reasonable person and what is just
absolute rubbish a great sort of example
of many of these phenomena that you're
talking about can be seen through the
lens of climate science and climate
change and very often you will hear what
would I call climate science deniers
site wrong anchor what we now know to be
incorrect understandings of aspects of
our world often from a hundred and fifty
two hundred or even three hundred years
ago or even longer in some cases as sort
of justification for being highly
skeptical of what the consensus on
climate change is today and what that
fundamentally seems to miss
it is how drastically the scientific
method has changed how we do science
over the last two or three hundred years
can you talk a little bit about that and
whether scientific misunderstandings
from 300 years ago tell us anything
about how skeptical we should be about
climate science today well the problem
is there's different kinds of I don't
know there's the I don't know 400 years
ago when we didn't know that atoms
existed and we didn't know Newton's laws
of motion we didn't know what light was
and Lizzie I don't know of today when we
understand an awful lot about the
framework but we might not be able to
give you a simple chain of logic that
leads to a point so some of these people
misunderstand that the other thing that
happens is that cherry picking data is
very easy humans you already have a
patent in their brain and if that is an
ideological pattern that says for
example I don't want climate change to
be true and they will look for things
that fit that pattern because it's
mental easier and the problem is is so
much data that quite often these people
in the case of climate skeptics and they
you know they found some data from East
Antarctica whether the small region
where maybe something is getting cooler
and they've gone oh well here is a bit
of data that supports my pre-existing
view so I'm going to ignore everything
else that something called motivated
reasoning which means that all the logic
in your brain that thinks it being
logical is actually just looking for
logic that already fits with what you
choose or want to believe to start with
and part of scientific training is not
to do nice to spot those biases and
people what I mean there are there are
but have been climate skeptics you have
been have had a much more open approach
to data so for example a few years ago
there was something called the Berkeley
climate project and where climate
skeptics funded superstitions who knew
nothing about climate science to just
look at the data mr. just look at the
data look for biases don't worry about
science just tell us other number you
know are things getting warmer and those
statisticians came out more strongly in
favor of manmade climate change than
even the IPCC reports and so there are
climate skeptic to have got that
ideological bias and they're looking for
patterns to fix it but they've been
honest enough to
to look at you no judgment unbiased
judgments of others and there was a
there was a great term opinion offered
in the New York Times written by the one
of the funders of that project he was
like okay it's real like I have been
convinced and to his credit he had
changed his mind based on the evidence
but humans really want things to fit
this motivated reasoning thing is very
powerful but it's part of the habit of
science and understanding the process of
science to be able to spot the flaws in
those arguments and it and it starts
with understanding the basic bits of
science so it's complicated but and
humans need to separate the other thing
about climate science which is difficult
is that humans need to separate the
science from what you should do about it
and one of the problems in that debate
is that it has been assumed that science
tells you what to do and it doesn't the
science says the world's warming and we
predict that these things will happen if
you know if we carry on the way we are
but that's actually not saying anything
about what society should do about it
that's a policy decision it's not made
by scientists and actually what a lot of
people were really attacking with the
changes that were suggesting they made
the mistake of attacking the science
because they assume that the science was
telling you what to do but the science
isn't telling you what to do it tell you
how things are and that is separate to
what to do if you want to have an
ideological arguments about whether you
should regulate things or not and how
much the government should get involved
in you know control your gets put this
atmosphere listicle argument is not the
scientific argument those two things are
very separate so there's lots of compute
you know there's lots of nuance in this
in this in these debates and the problem
is that once you've been you but too
much to do at leas complicated so human
brains tend to go with the easy option
which is either what they expect or
something that's simple to understand in
the bit of time that we have left could
you we've talked a lot about climate
change is a lens through which we're
talking about many of these issues of
understanding of science what are some
other important modern-day issues that
are being impacted in the way you
discuss science and storm in a teacup
that may be our audience is not thinking
of as consciously as climate change
which is probably on everybody's mind
when we have this
resolution well so many teen chef is
about them how the little bits of
everyday science that we can all see you
and play with an experiment also explain
big important concepts that matter for
energy generation for how the planet
work for how medical tests work and so
the point is that we can all play with
the simple principles you know how
things rotate how things fall how
gravity works you know how thinning
things work all that kind of thing and
then we can see exactly the same pattern
invidi important things in society so we
all have access and that's the
difference is that isn't science in lab
it signs that everyone can see and
everyone has seen everyone's seen their
toast will buttersidedown right if you
push it off a table and the same verse
physics also explains stuff about her
satellites work and how orbiting things
work and so the the crucial point is
that things like energy generation right
if we've got a planet with a huge
population growing we need to provide
energy for people to have a reasonable
standard of living the question is how
do you do it and you can get a long way
with understanding how we might do it by
understanding basic principles so for
example how a wind turbine works how it
generates electricity you can start
thinking about that using fridge magnets
and electric shocks you know that you
get on from your car on a cold day and
so these basic little things at the
bottom informs the cut the conversation
about the much bigger complicated things
and once people have confidence with
those little everyday things that it's
not about knowing the answers it's about
knowing the right questions to ask
everything is easy if you ask the right
question right so understanding the
framework is important for asking the
right question about these big
complicated issues and that's what's
going to let people see through all the
complexity the book is storm in a teacup
the physics of everyday life we've been
speaking with the book's author Helen
turski physicist at University College
London thanks so much for talking to us
about this thank you